let me let me let me pull up this story
and then i'll go into detail um this is
from reuters pelosi predicts what's his
name would fail in 2024 house run well
that's the headline but i think they
bury the lead at the end of the article
we see we see this
i say to my republican friends and i do
have some take back your party pelosi
said you have now been hijacked by a
cult that is just not good for our
country dude there's no there's no
remedy in this nancy pelosi is what
she's 80 years old
82. she is as crooked as they come joe
biden got a prosecutor fired in ukraine
because he was i won't say because but
he was investigating barisma a company
his son was on the was a board of
director on one of the board of
directors
joe biden flew his son on air force two
to china to negotiate a private equity
deal joe biden
just when he was put in charge of iraq
all of a sudden his brother gets these
lucrative contracts for doing
construction in iraq the dude is as
crooked as they come we know it and
pelosi has the nerve to say that
everyone else is in the cult you cannot
convince pelosi voters who keep
empowering that crooked corrupt behavior
that they are empowering crooked look at
this gavin newsom just won yeah they
won't even recall a guy who says you're
not allowed to go outside but i'm going
to go to a restaurant without wearing a
mask i think they just really like his
hair yeah
i think that we're
dealing with
with npc lemming type whatever the look
but you see penn gillette sitting there
with with newsome giving a thumbs up
these people have gone insane penn
jillette was it was a cato libertarian
yeah he was a question authority guy and
now he's sitting there with the guy
who's ruling by decree with a thumbs up
happy it's happening they've lost their
minds well they're using crisis as a
reason to abandon our traditions and our
representative government and they're
saying that because it's a crisis we now
get to abandon all the rules and do
these executive and you know overarching
things and what's being missed of course
is that it's during a crisis it's when
things are at their most dire that you
have to hold fast to your principles and
to your values and to your traditions of
government for sure what we need is a
representative government and what we
have is executives all over the country
making their own determinations even the
governors where i agree with what
they're doing which i would say in a lot
of cases i agree with desantis i agree
with some of abbott's stuff as well
i don't agree with how it's being done i
think it's being done in a completely
garbage way it's being done in a way
that undermines
the very values of our nation
and it's not okay it's just not okay but
you said also that these people are
gonna fight right these like uh
the new some supporting pelosi types
right they're not going to fight no no
no no i'm not they're going to get the
government to fight for them and then
what's everybody else and who are the
people who are in the police departments
and in the army it's those people
because right now in the army you have
that lieutenant colonel who resigned and
said i will not abide by this tyranny i
will not stand for the critical race
theory
all of these like
rational thinking individuals are like i
am out who will be left holding the
weapons so i'm not saying you're average
sitting at home filling out a mail-in
ballot gavin newsom supporter is going
to be in the streets yelling and you
know
flinging torches or something
but
a decent percentage of these people who
go march in the streets with the cop
doing the communist salute the red
salute while they're protesting
those people will fight antifa will act
as partisan engaging in violence
to to gain political power and territory
the police who remain are gradually
becoming more and more pro-establishment
authoritarian the libertarian-minded
people are quitting and resigning from
the military and the police departments
so it's only a matter of time well
there's also parallel economies and
governments that are being formed right
now in crypto and like the crypto
economy that is forming in parallel is
actually the funny part you know you
brought up uh anarcho communists and
libertarians in the beginning like in
new hampshire they both support bitcoin
and crypto because it's a fair sort of
you know
permissionless system that anyone can
participate in so there are actually
proposals for network states like balaji
who's a you know really interesting
crypto uh
character
has proposed the idea of a network state
and so like we have all the typical
geopolitical stuff happening but we also
have a crypto digital situation forming
this is the the piece of the puzzle
people need to understand
when you bank we were talking about this
in the members segment last night when
you bank there's no money it's a ledger
that's how your bank banking works i
talked to my bank after there was an
error and there's a problem and they
basically said we write down that you
have this number and then when you say
you you want to transfer it we erase the
number and the other bank writes down
you have the number money never
exchanged right cryptocurrency
is an alternate decentralized ledger
that allows funds to to move around the
world
outside of the us financial system
if there was going to be any kind of
conflict in the u.s it would require
support means of communication and
funding and with decentralized
communications becoming more and more
prominent particularly when we see
crypto
the us government can let's say you get
to the point where people are fighting
in the streets they are but i mean like
overt political factions with new flags
new hampshire secedes the federal
government's moving in and they say
we're going to cut off all their bank
accounts we're going to seize their
funds and seize their assets and they go
this is new hampshire
we use bitcoin here you can't do
anything to stop it
this allows people to exchange value
outside of the us government and it
strips the us government of the ability
to do anything about it which means
resistance can be funded
so if people whether it's antifa
claiming to be the resistance they'll
get funding through crypto a lot of
these alt-right dudes we're getting
massive amounts of money through crypto
the government has no question but
antifa too that's what i'm saying and
yeah and and that's an important thing
and i think it's important not to you
know make it like government versus
crypto because that's really not what
the situation is we just saw el salvador
you know bitcoin is legal tender in el
salvador now we want to encourage the us
to adopt bitcoin because that is in the
interest of the us it's going to make
the u.s stronger no it isn't yes it is
no it isn't absolutely the u.s has one
export you know we were talking about
this before it's the petro dollar okay
that's fine and that's going to be
happening but you know they they can't
stop the momentum so you know so it's
very very bad for us hegemony that we
that we will lose the petro dollar
that's fair but you want to be
you know
ready for the next evolution and if
you're not that's why like a lot of
investors will simultaneously fund the
competitors to their own investments
yeah imagine their bet yeah it's like
when you go to the roulette table and
you're like you get you've got first and
you know you know the first second and
third quadrant so you bet on two of them
hoping that it's like a greater chance
of winning but you win slightly less
that's basically what it is bill tell me
about this network state thing because
i've been thinking about something well
i don't know too much about but so we
have daos which are decentralized
autonomous organizations where people
are essentially
voting with crypto tokens on various
proposals around different projects and
the projects are governed by
the token holders of the project and
it's all you know cryptographically
secured and it's a public ledger and so
you could you know when you talk about
systems for voting
you know why not move voting systems to
cryptographic systems i mean that's
obvious so and that's really what
there's still a lot of challenges there
oh yeah yeah like how do you how do you
uh get someone how do how does someone
register into the system to be able to
vote using crypto
well there would have to be some sort of
connection between the decentralized
identity like in the crypto wallet tied
to like a driver's license so that you
know if a state was actually going to
become like a network crypto state then
it would have to be sort of connecting
its its databases identities with the
actual crypto addresses how do you clean
voter rolls
like clean what do you mean people die
yeah you have to get people off the
rules and then all the points yeah and
then all of a sudden you've got ids like
someone passes away and then a week
later someone's like i got access to
their crypto and you know so so it's a
good no there's definitely edge cases
that have well i i i do think
there is some you know we should people
are voting now anyway but yeah
well there was like uh
what was it like a couple dozen people
were found in one particular
jurisdiction but that i don't want to
make it seem yeah i i don't know
millions i'm just that's a name well
there was an old joke in philadelphia
which is notoriously shady uh
politically and there was a
long-standing republican on his death
bed and his best friend is this
democratic operative and the guy says
you know well at least as he's dying at
least i never voted democrat and his
friend says don't worry you will
that's terrible yeah i heard that joke
like 25 years ago i think
there is some promise with crypto in
terms of voting but i do think we can't
overlook the fact that
let's say new hampshire does because
they want to put this thing on the
ballot new hampshire wants to see
and in 2022 people will be able to check
off yep we want to succeed now
apparently a bunch of establishment
people are like no it's bad we don't
want to do this let's say they do
they don't got to worry about funding
they don't got to worry about being cut
off they don't got to worry about the
federal government being like we
sacrifice blood and treasure free admits
to the union and we will not let you
leave they'll be like what are you gonna
do about it we get our funding through
decentralized internet you know networks
we fund each other and people in new
hampshire are armed to the teeth
so what i mean what would really happen
in circumstance would the feds storm in
the national guard the army and try and
shut the state down and usurp civilian
authority they would fight for i-95 i-95
runs through vermont um and it connects
maine and what's the one right south of
there south of maine maine in
massachusetts they would sanction they
would block off their portland yeah they
take nine they try to the federal
government will try to take i-95 back
and
can't draw from the coast how would they
how do they take the how would they
change the coast
you think they oh yeah
if someone tried to secede from the u.s
they'd bring up the entire for the
entire military force to stop it okay
now i really want to see this i'm not
convinced
what else can you do if someone tries to
leave your union i mean you have to as a
government look at brexit
yeah they didn't do it they couldn't do
anything about it that was europe but
but still like we're at a point where
like even scotland if if scotland really
did vote for independence what can they
do are we going to see a whole another
campaign to go claim scotland for the
crown the only reason i think they're i
think they're uh working on that right
right right so my point is
we are beyond the era of violence
within to a certain extent what i mean
is
people will not tolerate
conflict and so if new hampshire says
here's our list of grievances here's the
problem and then images start emerging
of like new hampshire residents being
beaten and dragged the rest of the
country would be like stop stop what are
you doing this is bad we don't care
about new hampshire the federal
government would freak out but people in
idaho are going to be like whoa
i'll tell you this if people in new
hampshire really did vote to secede and
it was like boom there it is we have
people mentioning super chat they have
it in their constitution that they can
then if the federal government moves in
a bunch of other states are going to
file lawsuits they're going to make
declarations
basically what happened in the original
civil war the original the first one in
the united states the original i like
that several states seceded from the
union
the union union soldiers were at fort
sumter
and when conflict started i think it was
seven more states that went whoa
we're out we're done the moment you
started attacking
states that yeah i see i-95 is fort
sumter if they try and block the road
from massachusetts to maine by taking it
to a new country then the government
would try and take it back and that
would be like there's another thing too
which is
southern new hampshire is mostly just a
bedroom community for boston
so
a lot of people who live in that little
southern new hampshire area that borders
on massachusetts work in boston or work
in massachusetts um and i don't think
they want to get cut off from their jobs
i think i don't think they want to like
lose their jobs because they can't get
across the border if there's some sort
of issue yeah i wonder
let me say i'm not going to i'm not a
historian to tell you about the soviet
union or anything like that but they
lasted i think 69 years and then
collapsed they broke apart the united
states we got like 250 a little bit more
than that
it's possible that they're that we we
suffer a similar dissolution when i'm
thinking of network states i was
visualizing like a way for us to vote
across a network for things that aren't
local because localization has changed
now you can have a conversation with
anyone anywhere um it doesn't matter
and so
that we would we would have a system of
voting where i could vote alongside
someone in north dakota for something
that goes on in texas but then if the
power goes out we default back to this
local system or we could have both those
systems in parallel because the united
states is changing and it will
are you thinking of like something more
along the lines of a
completely direct democracy where
everybody votes on everything that'd be
terrible no not necessarily you could
still have a representation if you
wanted but more of a
an interconnected system of voting that
isn't based on where you live it's it's
based on what you do and so the people
that do certain things could vote on
that thing
and you know the problem you know the
problem is
uh the system of government they have
that we have is is beyond brilliant i i
reflect on the us government i'm just
like man did these dudes work it out so
you look at
the reason we we vote the way we do we
have districts we've got counties
is that we want to protect
say there's a small town that's got a
water reservoir and the people all move
there and they share and they bask in
this water and they protect it and then
a neighboring county says we want it we
want to vote to take it so we actually
have a weighted vote system with the
electoral college to grant some
protection some defense the united
states has the ability of minority rule
you know two uh democracies two wolves
and a lamb deciding on what's for lunch
republic is a well-armed lamb contesting
the vote
so that's that's really really important
the problem is
we've become a completely nationalized
information economy so where it used to
be that your local news outlet had your
city that you would learn about they
still exist for sure
now people are increasingly increasingly
getting their news from national sources
there was a joke i think it was i think
it was 30 rock actually because i've
been watching it where they were like
and now back to national radio that
doesn't make sense for you because we're
it's it's hot out there or maybe it's
not maybe it's cold it could be and so
what happens then is people vote based
on these
overtly national issues
so when you talk about you've talked in
before you ian you've talked before
about
direct democracy in a republic system
meaning
i think what you mean is we still have
the jurisdictions we still have a
defense for a minority for minority you
know smaller less populated areas to
have their votes heard but instead of
sending a representative they just issue
a county yes or no yeah as opposed to
having a reputation a direct republic
the problem with that is which is
interesting is that these people aren't
paying attention to local issues anymore
so when nestle comes in and starts
guzzling up all their water and
destroying it they don't know about it
so then when there's a vote put up where
it's like should nestle be allowed to
take water from reservoirs they go sure
why not
and then it's like oh wait that's our
water i didn't know that because we
don't pay attention locally anymore so
that's
regardless of whether they use your
system or anything else that is one of
the key problems right now like aoc
would not have gone elected gotten
elected or re-elected were it not for
the fact that she's got donors all over
the country in small pockets funneling
money into her district which she's
supposed to represent but she represents
the interests of a mass of twitter
socialists yes that's right
i i don't really see her representing
much of the bronx no i mean menstruators
i tell you this go to the birthing
people of the bronx right i mean she's
at birthing people right yeah she's like
go into the bronx her and corey bush go
up to a latina mom and ask her as a
birthing person how she feels about you
know gang violence and she'll be like
what she might laugh depends on how you
say it but yeah i think she'll say what
okay and you'll be like birthing person
you know aoc
is a congress birthing person
no one talks like that and she's not
representing the people of her district
the problem is these people don't know
or don't care and they vote for it like
nancy pelosi said
people would vote for this glass of
water if you put a d on it that's it
that's what she said that's what she
said about her district and aoc's you
put a d on a glass of water and people
will will elect it the uninformed voting
how do you solve that now that's another
conversation completely the the thing
about the uninformed voting is we've
completely crippled crippled our
educational system so it's not like
people are learning anything in schools
at this point
we have uninformed voters i think by
design
oh yeah schools are just corruption i
think that's part of it
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast irl podcast if you want to
see the full show come back to this
channel youtube.com tim cast irl monday
through friday at 8pm where you can
leave comments and super chat and we
actually will read your comments on the
show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want exclusive
members only content segments you can't
get anywhere else go to timcast.com
become a member and we even have full
bonus episodes thanks for hanging out
and we'll see you all next time
you